ben shapiro enrolled in at UCLA at the
age of 16 where he graduated summa [ __ ]
laude and Phi Beta Kappa that was
followed by Harvard Law School he's been
a nationally syndicated columnist since
the age of 17 I guess he's on what some
would call today an accelerated career
path he's editor in chief of daily
wire.com
as well as editor at large of Breitbart
news he's a frequent guest on radio and
television and he hosts his own radio
show which I guess he's maybe playing
hooky from this morning called the
morning answer which airs here in the
Los Angeles area he's the author of
numerous books including brainwashed how
universities and doctrine eight
America's youth he wrote that at the
ripe old age of twenty what do you want
to be when you grow up then other books
include primetime propaganda the true
story of how the Hollywood left took
over your television and bullies how the
left's culture of fear and intimidation
silences America he's a leading voice in
opposition to the movement to boycott
divest from and sanction Israel that is
taking place on so many of America's
campuses today but I hasten to add not
on hills dales
and he will be speaking this morning on
the topic politics on the American
campus please welcome Ben Shapiro
well it's a pleasure to be talking to
people who have experience with campus
that doesn't involve protesters and
screaming children and all the other fun
things that we tend to associate with
them the American left these days
so other than Hillsdale Americans
college campuses have become a breeding
ground for failure career or failure and
moral failure and emotional failure
there's a reason that when you go to
higher college students these days what
you tend to get is a group of entitled
brats you think they should get
six-figure salaries for having majored
in lesbian dance theory this is all
thanks to a perverse leftist ideology
that rewards subjective self
aggrandizement over objective truth so
let's start with the story is from
Tennessee Vanderbilt University I'm sure
some people in the in the audience know
where Vandy is is back in November last
November so remember last year there was
this whole media obsession that every
college campus every college campuses
all over America were rife with racism
they were just hot beds of secret racism
the KKK had branches that were secretly
meeting at frat houses all the black
people on campus were being targeted for
destruction the administrators clearly
hated black folks which is why they let
them in with lower SAT scores and so
there all sorts of protesters who showed
up at campuses all over America so 200
students at Vandy decided that they
wanted to protest the white privilege
and microaggressions of the
administration will define those terms
in just a few minutes they didn't give
any particular examples of what the
discrimination looked like but it didn't
matter if there was any actual fact to
back what they were saying they felt
victimized and that's the key they felt
victimized so they demanded university
diversity classes and a more diverse
student body not ideologically diverse
of course ethnically racially diverse
the next day after they had this big
protest a big bag of dog poop showed up
at the front door of the Bishop Joseph
Johnson black cultural center and
naturally the apocalypse ensued the
student activist group that sponsored
the original March rushed to Facebook to
announce what they called the vile act
and they said quote the violation of a
place that in many ways is the sole home
from
any black students is deplorable as many
of us sit in grief recognize that these
types of actions are what we speak of
when we note the reality of exclusion
and isolation of students of color and
specifically black students on our
campus so the police investigated and
nobody was arrested or prosecuted clear
evidence of white racism right well not
so much it turns out that the bag of dog
poo was not a racist attack in fact it
was left to a blunt and by a blind girl
with a service dog she couldn't find a
trash can so she followed what is
apparently normal procedure which is if
you can't find a trash can what you do
is you leave the bag of dog poop outside
the nearest inhabited building knowing
that somebody will come out in the
morning pick it up and throw it in the
garbage
so you'd imagine that this student group
would have a little bit of dog poop on
its face right I mean this is a little
bit embarrassing well not so much they
apologized but then they added quote the
needs of students with disabilities on
this campus are also marginalized so the
blind girl who left the dog poop where
they originally thought was some racist
KKK member who'd abandon the
cross-burning routine and instead
decided to drop dog excrement in front
of black buildings turned out to be a
blind girl and they now say that the
blind girl is a victim of campus
exclusion so this is how it goes at
America's College campuses there's a
phrase that you hear very often on
college campus these days check your
priveledge you hear this one a lot check
your priveledge and what this really
means that you're not part of one of the
victimized groups the the so called
hierarchy of victims that has been
created at college campuses America's
college campuses have one overriding
goal it's the same goal is that of the
American and international left and that
is to level all inequality of outcome in
equality of outcome equals inequity if
somebody in the room has four dollars
and somebody has one dollar it can't be
the person with four dollars work hard
and the person with one dollars blew
their money it has to be the person with
four dollars somehow owes at least a
couple of dollars to the person with one
dollar everybody should end up with 250
in this magical world America's Founding
Fathers obviously didn't believe in this
they believed in equality of opportunity
they've thought rightly that God or
nature provided mankind with rights to
life liberty and happiness these are
rights again
because the collective their rights
against the society the international
left the American left the campus lab
they believe that true opportunity can
really only be reflected in result any
inequality has to be the result of
inequity it's true for individuals it's
true for groups and we can't just
measure inequality in economic terms
it's not just the $4 $1 thing we have to
feel equal we have to feel it deep in
our bones we have to feel like we're not
being discriminated against like society
isn't colluding to harm us so on college
campuses the administrators who buy into
this stupid philosophy they've set up
their own little mini utopias and that
means great inflation so everybody gets
an a right because we don't want to have
anybody who feels like they are going to
get a C that means that they've been
discriminated against even if they can't
write a complete sentence government
sponsored tuition ensures that everyone
has an equal shot to go to college
regardless of whether going to college
is actually the best thing for all these
kids this is the Bernie Sanders utopian
vision everybody should have a
government sponsored slot in college you
know that idea is basically what ruined
American high schools and now is ruining
American colleges because it turns out
that kids didn't learn anything in
junior high we pushed them up to high
school said everyone should have an
equal high school education everybody
didn't learn anything in high school now
they're pushing them up to colleges
they're watering it down so basically
the only way you get a really good job
is if you go to grad school and soon
sooner or later sooner or later we'll
just be in school from the time we are
born until the time we die there will be
a two-day period at the very end where
you're expected to earn and then you
will die so college administrators are
working to ensure that every individual
on campus feels equally valuable this is
their goal and that's not really enough
because reality doesn't match the vision
right they're always going to be
individuals who underperform or groups
that underperform this happens
throughout human society it's happened
throughout human history there is no
society across planet earth as Thomas
Sol writes in his newest book in which
there is no inequality just doesn't
exist there has always been group and
individual inequality it always will
exist because people are differently
abled people have different abilities
people have different skills people have
different effort levels but because the
facts don't match the vision the left
instead blames the structure of the
United States right its structural
inequality that's the
our history our values our economics
this is the real problem to fail because
of the racist classist sexist homophobic
system both on campus and off and so the
system has to be torn out root and
branch and what the administrators do is
they make students their allies in this
effort which is easy because there's
something that feels good about being a
victim it gives you an unearned sense of
virtue that you get to parade around you
feel like a better person if you're a
victim if you're an underachieving black
woman then the campus culture will tell
you that the reason you're
underachieving is not because of
anything you did it's because you're
black and because you're a woman and
that's because society discriminates
against black people and women if you're
an underachieving gay Hispanic then
that's because the system targets people
like you for everybody who's left and
this is basically just what they call
white heterosexual cisgender males
cisgender for those who speak English
this gender means that it that you have
a in orientation toward your own gender
that is the same as your biology in
other words I'm a biological male and I
think I'm a biological male right that's
what cisgender means seriously I mean we
laugh but this is actually a thing on
campus cisgender has become a thing now
right because we can't discriminate
against people who are biologically male
but feel their feet we can't
discriminate against Caitlyn Jenner so
everybody else has to has to abide by
these silly linguistic conventions but
for people who are left the white
heterosexual cisgender males there is
one way that they can get out of the
unenviable position of being the only
people in America who are not victims
right according to the left and that is
they have to acknowledge their privilege
they have to check their privilege
because the system was built to benefit
all of the white heterosexual cisgender
males right forget the fact that there
are more white people on welfare than
black people on welfare forget the fact
that there are plenty of poor white
people all over the United States forget
the fact that in college admissions for
example white men are disadvantaged by
affirmative action programs not quite as
much as Asians by the way but they are
very disadvantaged by by all of these
programs so you have to acknowledge your
white privilege which means America is
bad in your bad and by saying that
you're bad that makes you good right you
acknowledge your guilt may a culpa may a
couple maxima culpa and now everything
is good
so none of this complies with the facts
and this is the problem because when
this white privilege faces up to reality
on campus they have to come up with
something else and what they have to
come up with is the use of force right
they have to come up with the use of
force so to digress for a moment here's
a brief history and this goes by the
title political correctness right
political correctness is basically the
campus use of force in order to shut
down the debate to create this own
vision of utopia where everybody is
forced to shut up because if you ever
utter the unalterable truth that some
people perform less well than others in
a free society then you must be silenced
so here's a brief history of political
correctness on campus because campuses
weren't always this way
but the remoulding of america's college
campuses has been a very long
intergenerational process encompassing
virtually the whole of the 20th century
and by the way not unique to the United
States Seoul writes quote the history of
the 20th century shows soft subjects
students and their professors were among
the biggest supporters of extremist
movements both fascist and communist the
former in Central and Eastern Europe
before World War two the latter in
countries around the world both before
and after the war proponents of soft
subject education to be liberal arts
education always have a generalized
interest in radical ideas because this
is what you get famous for this is how
you get a fortune or you don't become
famous or gain a fortune by talking
about the glories of Western
civilization you do it by ripping on
Western civilization the outlier is
always the person who gets the attention
and young people of course are happy to
ally with this because young people
always have a taste for revolution
particularly in prosperous societies and
prosperous societies young people have
nothing better to do and they have the
need to change the world and if the
world's already a pretty good place then
they still have to change it and so they
change it in a negative way well in the
60s all of this sort of combined to push
over all the weak neat administrators at
American universities and college
campuses then became bubbles of leftist
thought and they used as their tool
political correctness now when people
say politically correct it's become such
a buzzword that we forgot where it
actually came from the term political
correctness is a Maoist term right now
use the term
political correctness Trotsky's to use
this term also what it meant literally
was that what you were saying was not in
line
the correct political orthodoxy and
therefore you had to be harmed right
that's what political correctness meant
the left picked it up they said that
their goal wasn't to silence voices
instead they wanted to open up new
vistas of viewpoints by silencing people
free speech they said could only exist
in a place where there was no racism no
sexism no homophobia nothing offensive
then people would really feel free to
speak their minds all right this is the
idea so basic viewpoints when in basic
truths went out the window in favor of
leftist viewpoints victim groups
replaced actual truth and language
shifted that we didn't create these
quote-unquote
oppressive hierarchies that silenced
people who would normally have been able
to speak out if not for the evil white
infrastructure after the 60s and 70s
basically PC became a joke for about 20
years and then well really 30 and then
President Obama came along and President
Obama really issued in a new era of
political correctness on college
campuses and across the United States
because he promised a world of non
offensiveness a world in which Liberty
could be defined subjective as
full-scale offenses political
correctness says you don't even have to
be a member of a victimized subgroup you
don't even have to be victimized in
order to call political correctness and
shut down the debate you need to feel
victimized it's all about how you feel
so what this does is it incentivizes
everybody to become a victim in their
own mind because you have an advantage
now the minute that you claim that
you're a victim
you can now shut everybody else up right
anybody who talks to you I'm a victim
you hurt my feelings
shut up and go away this is what we call
fascism right but it's a fascism of
cowardice and I call on college campuses
I've called them the pantywaist fascists
they've fully embraced this this new
form of political correctness and there
are a couple of hot-button terms they
use microaggressions trigger warnings
safe spaces in white privilege I'm sure
you've heard all of these on the news
microaggressions trigger warnings safe
spaces in white privilege so what are
microaggressions you hear this one all
the time even the left makes fun of this
even while it still pushes it
microaggressions are basically we'll use
the definition given by Jonathan Hite
who's a psychologist over at NYU
he says microaggressions are quote small
actions or word choices that
on their face to have no malicious
intent but that are thought of as a kind
of violence nonetheless right so there's
so they're not offensive you're not
saying anything offensive but I take it
as offensive that is a micro aggression
so for example if you say I'm colorblind
you're in the middle of a conversation
about race and you say I'm colorblind
that is a microaggression because it
implies something that isn't true which
is that you're colorblind right because
that's that's aggressive to somebody
that makes me feel bad because if you're
colorblind you expect me to perform in a
meritorious fashion and that in and of
itself is a racist notion and I'm
totally serious here this is not a good
a joke okay if you use terms like he and
she this as this is a microaggression
because it offends the non cisgender
right if you ask where are you from
these are on lists of lips you can find
these in college guides now where are
you from is a microaggression because it
implies that you're not a native-born
person how about the subjective right
it's how offended am i subjectively not
whether this statement is objectively
offensive and of course nobody bothers
to ask whether such microaggressions or
freedom of speech they have to be
quashed so last year at University of
Missouri for example I spoke at
University of Missouri shortly after
they had this big blowup there and one
of the things that they had they
announced basically in advance is that
if people were using hurtful words
hurtful words people should call the
police
seriously that of course is
totalitarianism that's using the power
of the gun to shut people up right
you're literally calling men with guns
because your feelings were hurt that is
totalitarianism in its finest form and
it reaches even more ridiculous
proportions so for example at Brandeis
University which is just an uber left
campus in Boston if you even discuss
microaggressions it's a microaggression
so I mean it's it's beyond parody you
actually cannot make these things up so
last year the Brandeis Asian American
Student Association put out what they
called an installation in the public
square to quote bring attention to
microaggressions that are frequently
heard in and out of the Brandeis
community according to their Facebook
page so they put up a wall and then they
put up all these phrases like these
phrases like where are you from and are
you a he or a using the word he they put
all these on a wall to raise people's
awareness that these things were
microaggressions sure enough some
asian-american students felt micro
aggressed by the display itself so it
was removed now to prevent people from
being micro aggressed one of the other
phrases that's come into common usage is
the phrase trigger warning you've heard
this one too and trigger warnings are
the idea that before we say anything we
have to give you a trigger warning so if
I'm going to talk about rape on college
campus I have to say trigger warning I'm
about to talk about rape if you have
been raped in the past know anybody
who's been raped in the past read about
anybody who's been raped in the past or
know the definition of the word rape I
do not mean to offend you right that's a
trigger warning so colleges have now
required that certain classic works of
literature actually be accompanied by
trigger warnings so that people aren't
triggered the idea here being that
somebody's going to have like a Vietnam
flashback while reading East of Eden
again the point here is that nothing
subjectively offensive must occur under
under public under under under this
regime of political correctness right
perception is the reality
so once the microaggressions have been
put aside and once trigger warnings have
been issued then campuses are water
known as safe spaces right so the
implication here is clear that if you
are subjected to language with which you
disagree then you are now in an unsafe
space you require the protection of men
with guns you require segregated areas
in fact at university of missouri had a
bunch of black students who are
protesting supposed systemic racism at
university of missouri which has an
affirmative action program and no
objective evidence of racism on behalf
of the administration what they well
they were protesting it turns out that
there were some some mewling white
students who wanted
to join them as well some of these black
students the black students said we
don't want you here because you aren't
part of our micro aggressed population
right you haven't been aggressive in the
same way that we have we want a
segregated space in which to protest
right only black people which is a USC
right just down the couple hours out of
here the black students have been
applying for separate black housing that
show on separate black housing because
they think that it's a microaggression
or that require they require their own
black safe space right which is
something that the KKK would love right
it's both separate and equal it's
awesome all of this is actually making
America's young people not only stupid
but actually evil it's actually making
America's young people evil because what
this does is it creates an entire
generation of mentally and emotionally
stunted human beings who are completely
unprepared for the real world we're
going to have to face up to people who
disagree and realities that show that
your vision is wrong and you're going to
have to deal with people on the other
side of the aisle right Jonathan Hite
that psychologist he wrote quote the
recent collegiate trend of uncovering
allegedly racist sexist classist or
otherwise discriminatory
microaggressions doesn't incidentally
teach students to focus on small or
accidental slights its purpose is to get
students to focus on them and then real
able the people who have made such
remarks as aggressors right so the idea
is you're supposed to constantly be
policing the world around you for
microaggressions you're still supposed
to be looking to be offended you get
credit for being offended you're a hero
for being offended now for anybody who's
ever had experience with psychologists I
live in LA that means 100 percent of
people have had experience with
psychologists but for anybody who has
ever had experience with psychologists
you know that there's something called
cognitive behavioral therapy right this
is the most common form of psychology
that's now used cognitive behavioral
behavioral therapy this is where you're
having a chain of thoughts that leads
you to be depressed or anxious or upset
and what the psychologists will do is
attempt to teach you how to break this
bad chain of thoughts so in if your
micro aggressed by something the
psychologist so why don't you think it
through is it possible that the person
actually didn't mean to offend you and
you're just going down this road too far
you're getting upset you're getting
depressed
getting anxious over all of this
cognitive behavioral therapy is in fact
one of the only forms of psychology that
is clinically proven to work colleges
are now doing precisely the opposite so
if you say to kids you're not being
micro aggressed you're just being too
sensitive right nobody means to offend
you
you're just oversensitive now your micro
aggressing times - now you're really
ruining their lives and so what you've
created is this this subjective this
this world in which kids are rewarded
for their own subjective victimization
looking to be offended all the time it
also makes kid I said earlier it makes
kids evil it does it's a professor named
Roy Baumeister is another psychologist
and he writes there's this book called
evil inside human violence and cruelty
he says evil behavior generally Springs
from idealism that turns to violence
unjustified self-esteem and hyper
sensitivity these are three of the
elements of evil so we tend to think of
evil people as like James Bond villains
who sit in rooms and they have shark
tanks underneath their giant conference
tables and they laugh at the suffering
of others and that's not really what
most evil people are Baumeister says
people who think they're better than
they are will be the dangerous ones
hypersensitive people who often think
their pride is being assaulted are
potentially dangerous even when a
neutral observer would conclude that no
serious provocation occurred it is still
important to recognize that in the
perpetrators own view he or she was
merely responding to an attack going
back to the the word microaggressions
just think about that for a second it's
not an offensive statement they could
just call it an offensive statement it's
a micro aggression it's an aggression
against you and in normal life and
somebody aggresses against you if
somebody punches you you punch them back
right so now the rule is that if you say
something that micro aggress is somebody
they can basically punch you and this is
this is actually not just become a thing
on campus this has become a thing all
across the American left now quick
personal aside I was on CNN this would
men about six months ago and I was on
CNN to discuss Caitlyn Jenner being
given the heroism award by ESPN because
our definition of heroism has shifted a
little bit since Normandy
and while I was in while I was on CNN
they put me on the doctor on the dr.
Drew show which is watched by no one and
and he's a terrible host
so that aside so they asked me to be on
the dr. Drew show to talk about Caitlyn
Jenner's heroism and because the
producer is a former Jerry Springer
producer seriously he says he knows my
perspective on transgenderism which is
that transgenderism is a mental illness
okay you can't magically change from a
man into a woman the the transgender
surgery has exactly the same suicide
right after as before transgender people
tried to commit suicide at a 40% rate
because there is comorbidity between
transgenderism and depression and so you
know I went in I told them all this
stuff beforehand when you're on national
TV they always do a pre-interview so
they know sort of what you're going to
say well right before the show they say
okay we're going to sit you next to this
person named Zoey turn Zoey tur was
formerly bobbed her so Zoey tur is a
transgender woman raised a man who
thinks that he's a woman in had the
surgery to prove it his voice was about
an octave lower than mine and he and he
had about 20 pounds on me at least which
becomes relevant actually to this story
so we're so we're going through this
this entire rigmarole about about
transgenderism is Caitlyn Jenner a hero
in and the argument of everybody on the
panel is about five people on the panel
plus dr. drew the argument was everybody
was from everybody was is Caitlyn Jenner
a hero or should Caitlyn Jenner be
actually canonized as a saint that was
the argument on CNN and so they and so
they came back to me and I said I don't
understand why we're humoring delusion
right why is society humoring to lose
you're not doing anybody any good you're
not doing any good for transgender
people you're not doing any good for
confused young people you're not doing
any good for children who have to know
about gender roles you're not doing
anybody any good
and Bob terzo eater is sitting next to
me and turns to me and says you don't
know anything about biology and I said
and I said well actually I know that
every cell in your body is
genetically male except for some of your
sperm cells ironically which may just
carry an X chromosome right and and he
says you know we you don't understand
anything about chromosomes and I said
well what are your genetics sir
right and I didn't mean it to be
particularly offensive because he's a
dude and I called you'd sir
and so uh-huh it was the sir that sort
of set him off apparently he on national
television on national television he
reaches over and we're sitting you know
two feet from you not even maybe a foot
and a half from each other he reaches
over and grabs me by the back of the
neck on national television and says if
you say anything like that again I'll
send you home in an ambulance which
first of all doesn't make sense because
the ambulances don't take you home but
and so and I said you know this seems my
my actual reply I was really taken aback
like this has never happened to me on
national TV before because it's a crime
right and so like it's an actual battery
I'm a lawyer I know and so in and so I
said I was kind of taken aback and I
said it seems mildly inappropriate for a
political conversation and and what was
amazing about it though what was truly
incredible about it was not that this
incident happened to is that the entire
panel all of them universally say again
there are five more people on the panel
universally turn on me and say how dare
you offend Zoey you are deliberately
offensive to Zoey
that's why Zoey did that this is your
fault in other words it was a
microaggression
and it could be responded to in kind
with actual aggression Ryan didn't end
there by the way Zoey terazzo eater
walks off the set he says to me I'll see
you in the parking lot and then later
tweeted that he wanted to curb-stomp me
right and all of this is okay dr. drew
later said he thought that everything
was totally under control dr. drew did
so this is the way that the left things
and it starts on campuses so all of this
kind of silly laugh-out-loud ridiculous
nonsense about microaggressions this is
how the left moves toward actual fascism
there is a reason that in November 2015
Pew poll showed that 40% of millennia
people my age like 18 to 30 33 right
people 18 to 34 40% of them believe that
the government should be able to prevent
people from making quote statements that
are offensive to minority groups 40% 4
in 10 people my age or younger think 4
in 10 think the government should be
able to come into your house with a gun
and stop you from making statements that
someone feels are offensive
ok talk about the end of free speech
talk about the end of the country that's
the end of the country in real time and
it's happening on college campuses and
this is happening all over the United
States I spoke at a high school outside
of San Diego called Otay Ranch High
School and I was talking to the students
and one of the things I said to the
students is that people who are
permanently poor in the United States
are permanently poor as a general matter
because they're not good with money
right if you're temporarily poor that
could be because you can't upon hard
times get a health problem it could be
because you're you weren't able to hold
down a job it could be a variety of
reasons but if you're poor from the time
that you are born until the time that
you die unless you are physically or
mentally disabled the only reason for
that is because you are not good with
money definitionally and there was a lot
of poor kids you know parents were poor
sitting in the back of the classroom
they started to kind of boo and hiss and
I said please name me one person who is
fabulous with money who's permanently
poor in the United States at this point
an administrator gets up walks to the
front of the room and dismisses the
entire student body and says he has to
protect the student body from being
offended I'm supposed to speak in a
couple of weeks at Cal State University
Los Angeles the students some of them
are trying to shut it down of course one
of the professor's is actually
threatening he's offering to wrestle the
quote/unquote white supremacists who
invited me bragging online quote I lift
bro that's that's mild stuff and say
okay simmer down [ __ ] but he's it but
it's but this is this is mild stuff
right where he summers the the when I
was at Harvard live is during the Larry
Summers debacle for those who don't
remember Larry Summers Lawrence Summers
was the secretary of the Treasury under
Bill Clinton and he became the president
of Harvard and he was giving a speech
and in that speech he mentioned the
truth and it is a fact that when you
look at the bell curve for how women
perform in science if you look at the
upper echelon of how women perform in
science there aren't as many women in
the upper echelon of how when
performance science the bell curve for
women tends to be slightly above the
bell curve for men but the bell curve
for men has a longer tail in other words
he mentions this and he says maybe the
reason there aren't that many women in
science is because there aren't that
many women who are interested in science
and at the top levels there aren't as
many women as a proportion who are good
at science and he was talking about
statistics he was fired from his job at
Harvard University for saying that at
Yale University there was a professor
who said that he was ok with people
dressing up for whatever they wanted to
at he was a dorm supervisor he said
dress up how you want for Halloween none
of my business you dress up how you want
the students got that person to resign
this happened just a couple of months
ago Tim hunt who's a Nobel Prize winner
in biochemistry Tim hunt just lost his
job at the University College in London
because he made a joke about women in
the workplace even though his wife is a
scientist and it was a self-deprecating
joke about why there should be more
women in the workplace
so what they've done is by purging the
universities they've ensured that the
safe space continues to the next
generation and the next generation and
the next generation because remember at
the campuses college campuses and
professorial they basically work like
the old Soviet judicial system when you
retire you appoint your successor which
means that if you're a college professor
you're not going to be giving anybody a
PhD if their dissertation is on
underachievement in the black community
due to the increase in the welfare state
it's not going to happen so one of the
questions that the left frequently asks
here is why not what we're just creating
a better world right why shouldn't
society try to conform with the hopes
and dreams of the people who live in it
why shouldn't we adapt society to
feelings and perceptions
why shouldn't subjective realities trump
objective facts what does it matter if
we tow the PC line to make Caitlyn
Jenner or Zooey to feel better or if we
want to make black students on campus
feel better about not performing as well
or if we or if we want to make a woman
feel better about not earning as much as
the man next to her because she took
time off to have a baby why shouldn't we
just tell these lives why shouldn't we
frontally lobotomize ourselves to truth
if it makes people feel better and there
are professors who say this very Glasner
is the president and professor of
sociology at Lewis and Clark College
and he along with Morten Shapiro who
teaches at Northwestern they wrote a
piece I think this is in the if I'm not
mistaken the Wall Street Journal they
said as educators we seek to develop in
our students the cultural literacy that
reduces the chances that someone will
inadvertently belittle another wholesale
denouncements of young people's concerns
only hinder our efforts to do right by
our students all we're doing is trying
to make people feel better while doing
right by students means doing wrong by
the country they say that that's okay a
better world will result but it doesn't
obviously obviously because a society
that demeans achievement gets less of it
a society that incentivizes a victim
mentality gets more of it a society that
blames itself for individual failures
ends up destroying itself on the shoals
of self-esteem America is the greatest
social experiment in the history of the
world and it's the greatest social
experiment in history because it is a it
is an argument for dive for merit before
diversity the individual rights Trump
social engineering individual justice
individual merit individual performance
Trump's whatever we think of particular
groups and the result has been the most
successful nation conceived by human
mind or put into effect by human hands
and they're seeking to tear it down the
left is seeking to tear it down because
they live off the basis that they live
off the fruit of the land while
undermining the foundations that made
the society great in the first place
they will have equality of outcome
they'll elect Barney Sanders to do it
they will have equality of outcome they
will tear it out root and branch unless
we stop them and thank God for places
like Hillsdale College because the fact
is that only places like Hillsdale
College stand between an entire
generation and the abyss so thank you
all for what you're doing thank you for
supporting Hillsdale and thank you for
fighting back against a college campus
environment that really is the tip of
the spear in the leftist attempt to
destroy the foundations of Western
civilization and replace it with a
salted earth civilization that rewards
feelings over objective merit thanks so
much happy to take questions
we have time for a few questions please
raise your hand we'll come to you in
your opinion is the current situation on
academic campuses a continuation of the
influence of the Frankfurt School or a
perversion of it a continuation I mean
the Frankfurt School for people who
don't know anything about Frankfurt
School philosophy is a group of
philosophers in the 1920s in Germany who
were expatriates they moved to the
United States and basically infiltrated
American universities with an ideology
that suggested they realized the
Frankfurt School they realized that
Marxism when Karl Marx wrote Das Kapital
what he was trying to do was describe
how he thought society was going to work
it was actually descriptive not
necessarily proscriptive it was here's
what's going to happen he thought class
warfare would eventually break out and
destroy the capitalist infrastructure
when that's in World War one basically
dissuaded the international left of this
because there was no class uprising to
start World War one it turned out the
poor French people we're happy to fight
poor German people and all of them were
happy to fight poor Russian people so
when that fell apart
what the Frankfurt School decided is in
order to make this change happen we
can't just wait for this change to
happen we have to change the culture and
the Frankfurt School basically decided
to change the culture from the roots out
and in the 60s what they discovered is
that instead of using class which is
difficult it's difficult to get what a
poor white guy to sympathize with the
poor black guy instead what they would
use as a proxy is racial groups they
would use racial groups to tear down the
United States and the capitalist system
suggesting that racial groups are the
victims of capitalism if we can just
pose a racial group against a racial
group then that and mix in a little bit
of socialism in there we'll end up with
a more civilized world right need it's
the Soviet Union actually pushed this
message in the 60s when it would put out
propaganda about how the United States
was racist right not how the United
States was rich and poor didn't talk
about income inequality they talked
about how the US was racist and the
Soviet Union was a wonderful place for
people of all races when in reality was
just a crap hole for people of all races
so the so yes the Frankfurt School which
was led by people like Eric Hughes they
they it was it was very influential I
believe the full-scale conspiracy theory
that everybody was taken over by them
but I think that influential thinkers do
have influence beyond just the people
who read their books I mean there's a
wave that moves out and in academia
there's no question that people who
don't even know they've been influenced
by Frankfurt School ideas have been
influenced by Frankfurt School ideas
just as if you ask if you ask most
Democrats you know do you like Karl Marx
most of them will say no even though
they're buying directly into his
philosophy I have a question about the
alumni of the say I'm ivy or any goofy
schools why don't the Alumni pitch these
girls off here's a brown University for
one example is starting a fund drive for
two billion dollars what kind of good
are they going to do with that is
because they've got a bunch of
Roughnecks and ingrates down there
raising hell and more two billion
dollars so do some more of that thank
you very much so the question is is
basically why alumni don't do anything
they're there a couple of reasons why
alumni don't don't do anything the first
is that alumni really don't pay that
much attention to what's going on at
their schools they sort of see the name
on the paper and they say I went there
it was fun I enjoyed it I want to see it
continue to succeed they sign a cheque
and that's that's really how most alumni
deal with it I know my wife used to do
phone banking for UCLA this is how you
got people to give right you call them
up you say you remember how great your
experience was at UCLA we're still doing
that for thousands of kids give us some
money that's how most alumni actually
give the second reason is that there is
a bit of self-interest attached to
alumni giving in certain industries
meaning I went to Harvard Law School
Harvard Law School is depending on who
you look at either the first or second
best law school in the nation right it's
Harvard and Yale and they always battle
it out if I'm somebody who went to
Harvard Law School then I would prefer
that for the next 30 odd years when I
plopped down that credential people say
whew right if Harvard were to drop in
the in the college rankings in the law
school rankings down to 20 it's not
nearly as impressive that I went there
so there's a bit of self-interest
attached to the continuing prominence of
your school and until people tend to
give for that reason as well in other
words
the real question and this is a question
more broadly as why people don't let why
why people let other interests Trump
ideology and that's one and then
philosophy of life and that's you know
that's that is the difficulty of
American politics and politics in
general is getting people to understand
that their own personal self-interest is
not necessarily served by the short-term
gains to be made if they're undermining
the long-term foundations upon which
success is based it's clear definitely
up on everything yeah I'd like to ask
you a question which I will do now well
Hillary Clinton be indicted will hello
to Clinton be indicted well I'm I'm not
a clairvoyant but I'm gonna go No
and the reason I'm going to say no is
because the justice system is is
entirely corrupt at the top levels on
behalf of Democrats and Dinesh D'Souza
we'll spend time in prison but Hillary
Clinton will spend no time in prison
David Petraeus will end up having to
make a settlement with the government
Hillary Clinton will not my indicator by
the way that she's not going to be
indicted is that today Jay Carney came
out and said Obama was rooting for
Hillary right which is the first real
indicator that Obama is backing Hillary
in the race he's not he's not going to
endorse her full scale before South
Carolina but but he even that kind of
small signal the real question now is
whether the FBI's investigation is so
far that no one can stop them and I
don't buy it I don't buy it
it's you know listen I hope she's
indicted for purposes of justice and yes
of politics because I think that she is
poised to be one of the most damaging
she's already one of the most damaging
politicians in American history she's
the worst Secretary of State ever but
beyond that she's poised to be the
second worst president ever in American
history if she doesn't get indicted so
I'm written the same as everybody else
for her to get indicted I just I don't
trust the Loretta Lynch Justice
Department to do actual justice they're
too busy cracking down on the Ferguson
Police Department
hi I've noticed that this new
development with language like safe
spaces for instance and trigger warnings
is taken on a different kind of jargon
than previous revolutionary movements
it's really therapeutic and its
operating on an emotional level
and it seems to be resonating with kids
even at the high school elementary level
but I try to talk to my nieces and
nephews it's really evident there
doesn't seem to be a foothold for a
logical conversation to happen yes
because emotions seem to completely fill
the void if you seem to agree with that
so what do you think is creating that
environment because where I'm seeing it
it's a very difficult thing to even have
a conversation yeah I mean what's
creating the environment of feelings is
is basically that we're the most
prosperous nation in the history of
humanity
so I mean if you've ever dealt with kids
of very wealthy parents very often they
tend to be oversensitive and easily
offended and and when and these are the
kids of wealthy parents namely the
United States and so what are they going
to complain about the fact that they're
poor they're not poor the fact that they
have a rough life they don't so what
exactly is going to be their
world-beating change and there's nothing
more empowering to these kids than
saying the change that you seek is about
you right it's not even about the
society at large about you because your
feelings are now our gauge of success or
failure as a society I mean that's a
pretty empowering message I mean it's
almost it's it's almost a bizarre
leftist incarnation of Walt Whitman's I
contain multitudes you know what happens
to me is what happens to all of society
my feelings matter than anything else in
the more than anything else in the
universe which is why by the way when
you do argue with kids who are into this
sort of stuff it is imperative to
actually use emotional argument logic
does not work and that doesn't mean that
you have to make false arguments but you
can say you're being a fascist little
right and that's okay because the
reality is they are being fascist little
and so that's that's okay and the reason
that is because what they're really
doing what what kid what the left now
does is they make emotionally based
arguments about your character you're a
bad person right
the safe space argument the
microaggression argument isn't that
you're even saying something untrue it's
that you are a bad human being and the
only way to defeat you're a bad human
being in an argument to say no actually
you're a bad human being for suggesting
that I'm a bad human being without
evidence only a jerk does that right and
then once we get beyond the character
arguments then we can argue about logic
but it's going to be character arguments
all the way to the well then there's no
way to be a character argument with a
logical argument Mitt Romney
discovered this in 2012 right you cannot
make a logical argument and win people
over while your opponent is saying that
you kill people of cancer I mean which
was the actual argument against Mitt
Romney he fired people so that later
their wives would die of cancer this is
the Obama campaign and Mitt Romney's
campaign was that guy's incompetent okay
that's not so who you gonna vote for the
guy who kills people of cancer with his
magic Wall Street powers or the guy
who's mildly incompetent right so the
character arguments do matter and this
is why I encourage conservatives to see
the world as it is not as we wish it to
be logical arguments are not going to
defeat the safeSpace microaggression
mentality the only thing that defeats
that is showing these kids that what
they are doing is actually immoral it's
not just ineffective it's not just
counterproductive it's immoral it is
immoral to call the police if someone
hurts your feelings it makes you a bad
human being if you call the police
because somebody hurt your feelings it
makes you a fascist thug who wants to
use a gun against someone and when you
speak to them like that at least you can
embarrass them enough for just a moment
that maybe there's a gap I'm going to
ask a question on behalf of my daughter
and son-in-law we were visiting them
he's in the military well thank you
over over Christmas and he asked the
question we have four kids homeschooled
should we be saving money to send them
to college you've described a situation
he seems to sense that this is maybe not
a good place for his kids but on the
other hand college served him well his
wife so would you please respond so you
have to gauge your own kids and I think
it's different listen I went to UCLA I
went to Harvard Law there are no two
more liberal institutions leftist I
don't like the word liberal they're not
liberals or leftist there are no two
more leftist individuals
institutions on the planet than UCLA and
Harvard Law School I came out of
stronger conservative because I used
everything that I was learning as a as a
starter it wasn't the end point right it
was okay you want me to read John Rawls
okay well now I'm going to go and I'm
going to read Friedrich Hayek right I'm
gonna I'm going to read various
perspectives on the same issue so that I
know how to counter the argument so I
can argue leftist positions better than
most leftist can right so the so if you
have somebody who's a solid consider
what I say to parents is about college
if your kid is not a solid conservative
if your kid doesn't have solid values by
the time they're 18 that'll be they'll
be a leftist by the time they're 21
that's the way that this works ever all
your heavy lifting is done before the
college years so you sort of have to I
mean honestly I think that if your kid
isn't solidly in ensconced in values
before they hit puberty or in trouble so
it's so this is a long prior and a son
on the way I mean this is something I'm
gonna have to work on it's it's
something that you know I think that you
have to gauge this so what I say to
college students are really politically
motivated is go to leftist campuses go
to leftist campuses learn how to holding
your arguments become a weapon and what
that and what I also tell them is if
you're going to be on the leftist campus
don't be stupid if the professor is
going to grade you down for being
conservative in class right like a
communist I mean this is actually what I
did when I was at UCLA I'd argue with
the professor in class and then we had
things called blue books and blue books
were great because they were anonymous
they just used your student ID number
and so if you read my actual essays from
college they read like something
directly out of the nation and if you
you know and obvious it's not what I
think but that's how you get to graduate
summa [ __ ] laude at UCLA go to Harvard
Law School and then use all their
degrees against them so
one of the things that you mentioned in
your speech was that sooner or later
they're going to have to come out of
college and live with the reality of
life and making a living and doing these
types of things
there's enough kids in the Millennial
that have now come out of the colleges
how are they faring what are they doing
I mean they're faring poorly they're
shocked I mean they're they're kids who
are now suing their colleges is an
actual lawsuit suing their colleges
because they're saying I was promised a
job I was promised an income after I
come out of here right the the Occupy
Wall Street movement was all
disenchanted college kids who who got
out after that lesbian dance Theory
matron thought they were going to make
six figures somewhere and it turns out
nobody pays to watch people theorize
about lesbian dance so you know that so
this is so they end up you know going
and living in tents and in Central Park
and pooping on themselves so it's so
it's you know it's life is a rough
teacher what the left has tried to do is
extend kind of the period of adolescence
indefinitely right so now you're now
you're 26 and you're on your parents
health care okay by age twenty by age 26
I'd been married for a couple of years
and I was two years away from having a
kid and I met and I already had two
degrees in four published books you know
it turns in by the way that I'm that
that's actually I'm not even a success
story if you go back 50 years or a 50
years by the age of 26 you were supposed
to be fully ensconced in your job you're
supposed to have like three kids by that
point what we've done is prolonged
adolescence indefinitely
and so what bama's goal is what the
left's goal is what Bernie Sanders
Hillary the same goal and the same goal
is to extend College out right College
is not a place that's kind of a break
from reality College is the new reality
so we have to make all of human life
like college and this is what they think
Europe is which is why you're ups is
collapsed so it's Europe is going to
collapse and it's being invaded by
foreign forces and they're going the
barbarians are at the gates and Europe
is going to fall apart and it is falling
apart so we can play this game but it's
not going to end well so then the
problem is that because the education is
so poor instead of reacting against
their teachers at college you told them
everything was going to be hunky-dory
instead instead of having the kind of
all
quiet on the western front moment you
know where the where the former student
goes back to his classroom after World
War one he's in the middle of World War
one he goes back and he yells at his
professor and he says you're telling all
these kids the wrong thing you're
telling them that war is awesome instead
of them going back and yelling at their
professors they said no it just shows my
professor was right because Society is
unjust right the lack of my hundred
thousand dollar salary that's because
society is mean and so we have to
transform the society and that's why
young people again 40 percent back
speech codes in American life this is
why I think the last poll was nearing or
over 40 percent of young people are ok
with socialism like the actual socialism
because they don't know anything they've
been taught stupidity and how they feel
is all that matters I mean there's a
there's a video that's going around the
internet getting all sorts of play about
income inequality income inequality is
the stupidest issue income inequality
means nothing right I mean I'm I have a
lot of income inequality with Bill Gates
but I'm doing pretty well and I don't
care that Bill Gates is doing really
well the only thing we should all care
about is that there are poor people we
should figure out how poor people can do
better not how to make Bill Gates less
rich but what but this video is going
around and saying here's a poll of what
Americans think the wealth distribution
should look like and here is what the
wealth distribution actually looks like
and I watch this video in bewilderment
and young people love it and I watched
this video and bewilderment saying who
told you that you get to tell the
universe how wealth is distributed right
who told you that you have a moral se as
to how wealth is distributed it's
immoral it's evil it's wrong you're
going to have to steal people's labor
from them but people are not told this
and so they think that their own
subjective vision of what reality should
look like should govern what reality
actually looks like and it's only later
after eighty years of communist failure
that they realize oh that and hundreds
of millions of people dead that they
realize oh that was a bad idea for like
ten years then they go right back to it
could you please explain the unholy
alliance between the left and the forces
and the the Muslim supremacists
considering that the premises and the
the principles of both of them are
mutually incompatible
ok so they're not mutually incompatible
to point a they are to point B what I
mean is that it's a time
the left wants to tear down Western
civilization because it thinks it's
unequal the radical Muslims want to tear
down Western civilization because they
think it's evil so to the point of
tearing down Western civilization
they're pretty much on the same page
it's where they go from there that's a
problem right one side wants to build
the Caliphate and the other side wants
to build a communist utopia the the
reason that the left is routinely and
it's almost invariable but the left ends
up siding with the world's worst human
beings in every situation is because
again if you just go back to that
fundamental leftist principle that
equality of outcome is all that matters
in life that equality of outcome means
that something just is happening think
about it the real world is a place where
God designed it this way I believe this
God designed it not for every individual
but certainly for the vast bulk of
humanity if you do responsible good
things with your life you will be more
successful than if you do irresponsible
bad things with your life well if the
left believes the people who are
unsuccessful are more virtuous then what
that means that the non virtuous are
more virtuous right because the people
who are unsuccessful are generally not
doing good responsible things and the
left says well those people are victims
let's help them right so the Muslims in
the Middle East are victims of Israel
they must be victims of Israel cuz
Israel's rich and its neighbors are not
so they must be victims well the real
reason the Muslims the Palestinian
Muslims for example are poor is because
they spent all the money that has been
given to them hundreds of billions of
dollars all the money that's been given
to them over the course of decades and
they've spent it on terrorism and they
spent it on stocking it away in their
bank accounts of Yasser Arafat and
Mahmoud Abbas and they spent it on
garbage and they spent it on anti-israel
propaganda the real reason they're poor
but the left looks at it and they say
they're poor that means they're virtuous
this is why I hate it really despise it
when Republicans do the whole I'm a
better person because I have a rags to
riches story you weren't a better person
when you're poor okay no one is a better
person just because they're poor by the
way no one's a better person because
they're rich all that wealth is a
measure of how many voluntary exchanges
you engaged in in a free market that's
all that that's all that the wealth is
but the the idea for the left is that
all inequality is evil therefore the
people who are unequal at the top are
evil in the people at the bottom are
virtuous which is why you'll hear people
on the Left say things like they like
small business but they hate people who
are big business like the Walmart family
right the Walton family they're terrible
well what are they terrible when they
were just a family let
millena when it went exactly did they
transition over into evil right when
they became successful enough because
their success meant by necessity
according to the leftist worldview they
were depriving others of their fair
share and Bernie Sanders said this right
after winning New Hampshire the other
night and this is Bernie Sanders this
entire thing he says the principle of
America is the principle of fairness
which makes me want to vomit and never
stop vomiting the principle of America
is not fairness of outcome and he was
talk about fairness of alchemy so it's
unfair that 1% of the population lives
with more wealth than 90% of the rest of
the population and well maybe or maybe
it's not unfair because it turns out
that 1% of the population is hiring the
other 90% of the population to actually
provide their services in labor we have
time for one more question
hi mr. Shapiro I'm a community college
teacher and so I I paid union dues to
the CTA in the NEA and as you can
imagine I'm not real happy about that
don't let them get a hold of this tape
yeah I'm gonna blur out his face and no
worry do you have any hope I believe the
Supreme Court recently heard oral
arguments Friedreich's versus ETA any
any hope that that might come out yeah I
mean there is hope that that might come
out the right way it really depends on
you know whether Justice Kennedy had a
solid bowel movement the morning I mean
basically the
I mean all Supreme Court arguments
basically boil down to this vital
question of whether he took his
Metamucil
it's it's a Justice Kennedy
theoretically has an overriding
philosophy of what he thinks of his
individual liberties so anything that
allows you to do more stuff on a bite on
your own is something we should allow so
he foods in favor of gay marriage
because of allow gays people it allows
gay people to get married he's in favor
he's against you know campaign finance
reform because he thinks people should
be allowed to spend money on politics so
presumably theoretically he could vote
the right way on this case saying
teachers should be allowed not to have
to give their money to a union that uses
that money to push certain political
causes which is what the case is about
so it's possible that Justice Kennedy
comes out the right way I hate hate hate
that we live in a system where we have
to wait for the kadhi on the hill to to
dictate to us what our lives are going
to be like in perpetuity it's disgusting
to me it's a perversion of the
constitutional order and I wrote at
Harvard Law School I wrote my entire
Harvard Law School third-year paper on
the idea that Martha that Madison versus
Marbury is is wrong wrongly decided that
marberry versus madison is wrongly
decided that basically the supreme court
should not have the power of judicial
review because the founders didn't
believe any human beings should be
invested with that much authority to
destroy the Constitution if they saw fit
and in fact Hamilton clearly writes in
Federalist 78 he talks specifically
about how if the court should start to
exercise will over over
constitutionalism over over basic
philosophy of government then it's it's
betrayed its entire purpose so it's ads
me that conservatives have been
relegated to waiting around and by the
way this is why the status thing to me
of all about this election is that if we
lose this election or if Donald Trump
wins the election if we you know even if
any of these things happen if
conservatives lose the election there
are at least two justices who are
probably going to step down maybe three
or four in the next four to eight years
and so we could be living under the rule
of Elena Kagan who I know and she's not
someone who's rule you really wish to be
living under her so well that that's I
guess that's all we have time for but
thank you very much really appreciate it